we've got one week left until thor love
and thunder hits theaters uh morgan saw
it did you love it i loved it so weird
and wacky but so entertaining yeah so
for a lot of people i think the film
will take the top spot when we're
talking about maybe the best of the best
superhero films i'm gonna agree with
that and it seems that rolling stone is
on the same wavelength counting down the
top 50 superhero films of all time now
for the full list you can head over to
rollingstone.com and if you don't want
to be spoiled go do that now and then
come back here because we're about to
break down the top three
[Music]
so director james mangold brought a
gloomy dystopian decapitation pact take
on the last days of hugh jackman's
wolverine that for fans of the old
comics really brought what we knew of
the x-men into a more adult noirish
space he was at his all-time best in the
character for his final bow and patrick
stewart's performance as the world's
most powerful mutant way laid by
dementia was award-worthy
[Music]
hello peter all right so the number two
film on the list surely hits home for
spider-man fans and i have a feeling
toby maguire's appearance and spider-man
no way home might have bolstered his
spot on the list fun fact the original
spider-man was going to feature both
green goblin and doc ock but director
sam raimi worried that it was too much
for one film enter spider-man 2 where
alfred molina got his mecha tentacled
introduction into the cinematic universe
and you have one of the best villain
performances in any comic book movie to
date and one that when revisited felt
like visiting with old friends
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
[Music]
the critical crown jewel of the marvel
cinematic universe ryan coogler's epic
combines widescreen thrills with a
glorious afrofuturist aesthetic proving
that you could pair a filmmaker's
sensibilities with a big budget mcu film
that slaps at the box office late
chadwick boseman will forever live on as
t'challa and the film might have been
the first time since molina that we were
sad to see the villain michael b
jordan's multi-layered eric killmonger
leave us at the end i am your kid now
what happens now
determines what happens
to the rest of the world
all right so we want you to let us know
if you agree or disagree with rolling
stones top three and i want to know your
thoughts carlos on this what films would
you choose to take the top spot the
number one spot that's really tough you
know what i'm surprised by on this list
is that the dark knight wasn't higher
for the longest time it was like the
number one superhero movie and i guess
you know in storytelling and quality
there have been a lot more really great
superhero movies in recent times um
black panther is a fantastic movie i
would love to see like i love the really
fun goofy mcu movies too and ragnarok
would go a lot higher on that list for
me
i haven't seen love and thunder yet yeah
if you liked ragnarok then you will love
this so yeah i'm actually gonna go on
the same page as you guardians of the
galaxy it's number 15 on this list i
actually think it should be higher and
not that it's the best movie you know
the best superhero movie but it really
changed the game in time in terms of the
tone yeah i felt like yes i loved the
dark knight trilogy i thought that was
so beautiful but it was fine fun to have
a lot of levity when it comes to these
superhero films and i feel like the thor
films really took a page from guardians
of the galaxy now the thor films are
some of my favorite superhero movies so
yeah i think guardians i think this is a
good top five the one way i will stray
from this though um my personal favorite
superhero film of the last however many
years is spider-man into the
spider-verse a lot of people say it's
their favorite spider-man movie for me
it's like the top superhero
film at least for the last i don't know
how long yeah you know why because it
was unexpected i didn't expect that an
animated spider-man movie would be
better for me more fulfilling for me and
more entertaining for me than other
live-action spider-man films yeah i'm so
excited for the sequel we can't wait for
that
you